Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. What passing bells for those who die as cattle. Only the monstrous anger of the guns, only the stuttering rifles' rapid rattle can patter out their hasty orisons. The opening of Anthem for Doomed Youth by Wilfred Owen, a famous war poet who died in action on the 4th of November, one week before the armistice brought peace at last to the Western Front. And it's kind of indicative really of the way that people in Britain have come to see the Western Front. From Wilfred Owen you can trace a line to the concept of lions led by donkeys,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。哀-悼如畜类者之丧钟为何物？唯有巨炮之狂怒怪啸，唯有机关枪断续急促的哒哒声，能草率地为他们呢喃祷词。这是威尔弗雷德·欧文（Wilfred Owen）的诗作《为夭折青年的颂歌》（Anthem for Doomed Youth）的开头。他是一位著名的战争诗人，于 11 月 4 日在战斗中牺牲，就在停战协定最终为西线带来和平的一周前。这实际上有点说明了英国人看待西线战场的方式。从威尔弗雷德·欧文，你可以顺藤摸瓜地追溯到一个概念——“雄狮由毛驴率领”，
the joke in Blackadder of Haig making yet another gargantuan effort to move his drinks cabinet six inches closer to Berlin. And Dominic Sambra, you've actually written a book on the First World War. Is that right? A children's book. A children's book, yeah. Yeah, but that's fine. I mean, so you're kind of immersed in all this. I have been.
正如电视剧《黑爵士》（Blackadder）中调侃道，黑格（Haig）又做出了极其巨大的努力，把他的酒柜往柏林方向挪了六英寸。多米尼克·桑布拉（Dominic Sambra），你实际上写过一本关于第一次世界大战的书。是这样吗？一本儿童读物。一本儿童读物，是的。对，不过没关系。我是说，所以你基本上沉浸在所有这些之中。我确实如此。
This hasn't been published yet. It's been published just before Christmas. So I have... It's such a fascinating subject, Tom. And as you say, that... It's funny because I was thinking when you were doing that, when you were reading that poem, that we did that... Did you like my sombre voice?
这本书还没出版呢。它将在圣诞节前夕出版。所以我……这是一个如此迷人的主题，汤姆。正如你所说，那……说实话，当你在读那首诗时，我在想，我们做了那个……你喜欢我阴郁的嗓音吗？
I thought it was beautiful. I think if the history doesn't work out, and who knows if it will, then a career as a reader of poetry audiobooks. War poetry. Yeah, war poetry. I think you'd be great at that, Tom. Thanks, Doreen.
我觉得很美。我想，如果历史这条路走不通——谁知道呢，也许走得通呢——那么当一名诗歌有声书朗读者的职业……战争诗歌。对，战争诗歌。我觉得你很适合这个，汤姆。谢谢，多琳。
Appreciate that. But anyway, I was about to say, Wilfred Owen, I did that at GCSE. And pretty much exactly that moment, Blackadder Goes Forth was going out on whatever it was, BBC One. So I was, as a teenager, completely steeped in that idea of the Western Front as a senseless waste. I mean, that's the classic things that people say about it. Or what is it good for? Yeah, precisely.
非常感谢。不过话说回来，我本来想说，威尔弗雷德·欧文，我在 GCSE（普通中等教育证书）考试时考过。几乎就在那一刻，《黑爵士第四季》（Blackadder Goes Forth）正在 BBC One 或其他什么台热播。所以作为一个青少年，我深深地沉浸在“西线战场是一场毫无意义的浪费”这种观念中。我的意思是，那是人们对它的经典评价。或者说，战争有什么用？对，完全如此。
And actually, it was quite invigorating later on to start reading these books that said, actually, no, no, it was not a senseless waste. A lot of people on the Western front actually enjoyed it. The generals were much more canny than posterity kind of allows. And as it happens, we've got one of the absolute kind of key figures in that argument, professor gary sheffield anyway tom you've probably got a better introduction for him than i do well no i absolutely i mean gary sheffield is you know i mean he's completely transformed the the understanding of the first world war so really there's no one better to have on the show to to look at the history of the western front but also
事实上，后来开始阅读这些书籍时，感觉非常振奋，它们说：其实不然，这不是一场毫无意义的浪费。西线战场的许多人其实很享受这段经历。将军们比后人所认为的要精明得多。碰巧的是，我们请到了这一论点中最核心的人物之一——加里·谢菲尔德教授（Professor Gary Sheffield）。无论如何，汤姆，你可能比我更适合介绍他。哦，不，当然，我的意思是，加里·谢菲尔德，你知道的，他彻底改变了人们对第一次世界大战的理解——所以真的没有人比他更适合做客节目，来探讨西线战场的历史，以及
the various ways in which it's been understood um and I guess, Gary, the book you asked me to mention before we started this podcast was Forgotten Victory, the First World War, Myths and Realities. So I guess we're going to be talking quite a lot about myths and realities in this show. I think the title gives a little clue to my views, yes. Okay. Well, before we get on to the myths and realities, could you just give us a sense of why the Western Front comes into existence? I mean, basically, it's because the war breaks out in the summer of 1914. And to begin with, it's very mobile, isn't it? That's right. Essentially, the Western Front comes into being because the
人们理解它的各种方式。嗯，我想，加里，你在我们录播客之前让我提的那本书是《被遗忘的胜利：第一次世界大战的误区与现实》（Forgotten Victory, the First World War, Myths and Realities）。所以我想我们在节目中会讨论很多关于误区和现实的话题。我想书名已经对我的观点有所暗示了，是的。好的。好吧，在我们讨论误区和现实之前，能否先给我们讲讲西线战场是怎么形成的？我的意思是，基本上是因为战争在 1914 年夏天爆发。而且一开始，它是非常机动的，对吧？没错。从本质上讲，西线战场的形成是因为
German attempt to win the war very quickly in the West fails. That the Germans, well, historians debate how close they came to defeating the Allied armies, primarily the French, because of course, the British army at this stage is very small. And so Gary, the measure of success for the Germans would have been to capture Paris. Is that basically? That's what they were aiming to do. Whether that actually would have knocked France out of the war is another matter. But they don't succeed in capturing Paris. And perhaps even more importantly, they don't succeed in inflicting a crippling blow on the French army.
德国在西方迅速赢得战争的企图失败了。德国人——嗯，历史学家们一直在争论他们距离击败盟军（主要是法军）究竟有多近，因为当然，当时英国军队的规模非常小。所以，加里，对德国人来说，成功的标准就是攻占巴黎。基本上是这样吗？这就是他们的目标。至于这是否真的能让法国退出战争则是另一回事。但他们并没有成功攻占巴黎。也许更重要的是，他们没能对法军造成致命的打击。
Basically, what the Germans are hoping to do in 1914 is to repeat 1870, when the German field armies defeated the French field armies in a matter of months. And for a whole range of reasons, that does not happen in 1914. Instead, what happens is that both sides stumble upon something they've really known about already. That is that if you are about to be outflanked or defeated, you get your soldiers to dig holes in the ground, long, thin holes. You put your soldiers in them, in these trenches, and suddenly it becomes much more difficult to kill these soldiers for the simple reason that if you put a man in a hole, give him a bit of head cover, put a bit of barbed wire out in front, he's actually
基本上，德国人在 1914 年希望做的是复制 1870 年的辉煌，当时德国野战军在几个月内就击败了法军野战军。由于各种各样的原因，这在 1914 年并没有发生。相反，发生的情况是，双方都偶然发现了一个他们其实早就知道的事实：如果你即将被包围或击败，你会让士兵在地上挖洞，又长又细的洞。你把士兵放进这些战壕里，突然之间，要杀死这些士兵就变得困难得多了，原因很简单：如果你把一个人放进洞里，给他一点头部掩护，在前面拉一点铁丝网，他实际上
quite a difficult target to hit. But the poor so-and-sos who have to advance across the open towards the trenches are of course much more vulnerable. And add to the fact that by 1914, weapons are extremely powerful. I mean, there's been a revolution in firepower over the last hundred years. Because don't forget, 99 years before the First World War breaks out is the Battle of Waterloo, in which you have armies basically standing up, you know, a few yards from each other, blazing away. By 1914, that is no longer possible because of the power of the weapons, the sheer size of the armies, which go from being perhaps 100,000 strong thereabouts at Waterloo to millions strong. And all, of course, these are major industrial powers
会是一个很难被击中的目标。但那些不得不暴露在开阔地带向战壕冲锋的可怜虫们，自然就脆弱得多了。再加上到 1914 年时，武器已经极其强大。我的意思是，在过去的一百年里，火力经历了一场革命。因为别忘了，第一次世界大战爆发前 99 年是滑铁卢战役，当时的军队基本上是列队站立，距离仅几码，互相猛烈开火。到了 1914 年，由于武器威力的提升以及军队规模的纯粹膨胀，这已经不再可能了。军队规模从滑铁卢战役时的十万人左右（或类似规模），暴增到数百万之众。当然，所有这些都是工业大国，
backed by vast economies, which become even more powerful as they are developed to support the war effort. Cut a long story short, all this means is that the armies are unable to break the deadlock, which comes into being by the middle of November 1914. And it's in place largely, although not entirely, until the spring of 1918. And in big handfuls, it's fairly easy to explain in technical terms why. It's that the defender, having these man's in a hole I've already mentioned, can bring a vast amount of firepower to bear and also that when an attacker uh breaks into an enemy position it normally they are so weakened by the effort that they they simply don't have enough men to throw through to exploit the gap that's made
背后有着庞大的经济支持，随着它们为支持战争努力而不断发展，这些经济变得更加强大。长话短说，所有这一切意味着军队无法打破僵局，这种僵局在 1914 年 11 月中旬就已经形成了。而且它在很大程度上（尽管不完全是）一直维持到 1918 年的春天。简单来说，从技术层面上解释原因其实相当容易。那就是防守方把人放进我刚才提到的洞里，可以倾泻出巨大的火力；同时，当进攻方突破敌军阵地时，通常他们由于精疲力竭而极度虚弱，根本没有足够的人手投入进去扩大战果，
and and also because they lack uh communications in the way that they would have in the Second World War by radio, or they lack the ability to pass messages by courier or rider or something, as had been the case perhaps even 50 or 60 years before, because armies are so big and so dispersed that they simply can't sum up reserves at the right place at the right time. Of course, the defender who is dug in has telephone wires buried deep beneath the ground, and he could actually get a message back and rush people up to the right place at the right time. And what happens is that over the next four years that the armies on the Western Front, the French, the Germans, the British, struggle with coming up with technological ways of breaking this deadlock. In the end, they do, but it's enormously bloody. And in a sense, the answer to the reason, to the question, why the casualties are so heavy, is that if you fight that sort of war,
而且由于他们缺乏像第二次世界大战中那样通过无线电进行通讯的能力，或者缺乏像五六十年前那样通过信使、骑兵或其他方式传递消息的能力——因为军队规模太庞大、太分散，以至于根本无法在正确的时间、正确的地点集结预备队。当然，那些坚守阵地的防守方在地下深处埋设了电话线，他们实际上可以通过电话传回消息，并在正确的时间、正确的地点把援军调上来。于是，在接下来的四年里，西线战场的军队——法军、德军、英军——都在努力寻找打破这种僵局的技术手段。最后他们确实做到了，但这付出了极其血腥的代价。从某种意义上说，对于“为什么伤亡如此惨重”这个问题，答案就是：如果你进行那种战争，
that are the sorts of casualties you end up with. And really, the failure to come up with some sort of compromise peace, which is a political, not a military decision, condemns the armies to fight those sorts of battles. Now, you can argue about the competence of generals and competence of individual armies, but they're the fundamental reasons why the Western Front turns out to be as stalemated and as bloody as it is. So if we go back to the autumn of 1914, so the Germans have been pushed back from Paris at the Battle of the Marne. They've ended up on these, they have a race to the sea, don't they, where they try to outflank each other. And they end up with these lines etched into the map of Europe.
你最终就会承受那种伤亡。说到底，未能达成某种妥协和平（这是一个政治决定，而非军事决定），注定了军队只能去打那种战役。现在，你可以争论将军们的指挥能力和各自军队的效能，但这些才是西线战场最终陷入僵局并如此血腥的根本原因。所以，如果我们回到 1914 年的秋天，当时德国人在马恩河战役中被从巴黎击退。他们最终来到了这些地方，他们进行了一场“奔向大海”的战役，对吧？双方试图迂回包抄对方。最后，这些战线被镌刻在了欧洲地图上。
And is this, so they tell the soldiers to dig and they dig the trenches. Now, is this something that people, there was a revelation to them. I mean, so Dave Walters, who's a regular listener to the Rest Is History, has said, you know, did each side expect the war to be so static?
那么，当他们告诉士兵去挖洞，士兵便挖了战壕。这在当时对人们来说是一个启示吗？我是说，《历史的余烬》的忠实听众戴夫·沃尔特斯（Dave Walters）曾提出过这样的问题：双方是否都曾预料到战争会如此陷入僵局？
So they have the technology. I mean, they know that both sides have got machine guns. They know they've all got barbed wire and all these things. But is this a great shock to them, the generals and the soldiers of this? It's putting it too strongly to say it's a shock, but it certainly comes as an unpleasant surprise, because they are well aware that conflicts of this sort can be stalemated.
所以他们拥有这样的技术。我的意思是，他们知道双方都有机枪。他们知道双方都有铁丝网和所有这些东西。但这对于将军们和士兵们来说，是一个巨大的打击吗？说这是“打击”未免有点过头了，但这确实是一个令人不快的意外，因为他们很清楚这种冲突可能会陷入僵局。
Only 10 years before the Russo-Japanese War had seen a sort of Western Front-style conflict in Manchuria. And so you had trenches, you had stalemate, all the rest of it. The thing is, this was broken after about nine months, a year, for a whole host of reasons that was not possible on the Western Front. So nobody really ambiguous. And you had the British, actually, the most recent example of modern warfare was the Second Boer War in South Africa, 1899 to 1902. And the lessons from that war were rather different from those of Manchuria. And so people came into wars not necessarily having drawn the wrong lessons from history, but have not necessarily got all the lessons in the right balance the right balance so right at the beginning of of the first world war people still have a lot of faith in cavalry don't they so the french go famously
就在仅仅十年前，日俄战争就在满洲见证了一种类似西线战场风格的冲突。所以当时也有战壕，有僵局，诸如此类。问题是，大约在九个月到一年后，由于各种在西线无法实现的种种原因，这种僵局被打破了。所以没有人真正……情况很含糊。而且英国人——实际上，现代战争最近的例子是 1899 年至 1902 年在南非爆发的第二次布尔战争。那场战争给人的教训与满洲战役颇有不同。因此，人们投入战争时，并不一定是从历史中吸取了错误的教训，而是没有把所有的教训放在正确的平衡点上——没有达到正确的平衡。所以在第一次世界大战刚开始时，人们对骑兵仍然抱有很高的迷信，对吧？比如法军就 famously 骑着马、穿着彩色军服、戴着漂亮的头盔、挥舞着军刀到处跑；而道格拉斯·海格（Douglas Haig）当然是一位伟大的骑兵将领，对吧？……他不是，他现在也不是。我为什么这么说呢？如果你认为传统的骑兵就是挥舞着军刀之类的话，不，他可不是。因为在海格等改革派看来，到了这个阶段，骑兵已经将自己重塑为一种实际上是新型战争兵种的军队。因为在 1914 年，英国骑兵（无论如何）行军和骑马的时间一样多。他们受过很好的轻武器训练。他们配备有机枪。
riding in colored uniforms and nice helmets and swords and all that sort of stuff and douglas haig of course is a great cavalry man isn't he uh he isn't he and he isn't now why i say that is if you if if by by a traditional cavalryman you know lots of waving swords and what have you no he isn't because cavalry as far as the likes of hague and the reformer school are concerned by this stage has reinvented itself as effectively a new form of as a new arm of warfare. Because cavalry in 1914, British cavalry anyway, they walk as much as they ride. They are very well trained in firearms. They have machine guns.
身着色彩鲜艳的制服、戴着漂亮的头盔、佩剑等等，道格拉斯·黑格当然是一位伟大的骑兵将领，不是吗？嗯，他是不是？现在我之所以这样说，是因为如果你认为传统的骑兵就是大量挥舞着战剑之类的话，不，他不是。因为在黑格和改革派眼中，到了这个阶段，骑兵已经把自己重塑为实际上的一种新式作战力量。因为在1914年，无论如何，英国骑兵行军和骑马的时间一样多。他们受过很好的火器训练。他们拥有机枪。
They have light artillery with them. And the idea is that they will form, effectively, a sort of mobile column, which we see much use in the Second World War and beyond. The difference is, of course, you're actually using horse flesh rather than vehicles. So yes, Haig does believe in charging forward, the armblanche, if the moment is right. These moments actually do occur during the war, but it's not traditional cavalry. And interestingly, in 1914, the British
他们随身携带轻型火炮。他们的构想是，他们将有效地组成一种机动纵队，我们在第二次世界大战及以后看到了这种战术的大量应用。不同之处在于，你使用的是马匹而不是车辆。所以，是的，海格确实相信如果在时机成熟时发起冲锋——即“全线突击”（élan）。这些时机在战争期间确实出现过，但这不是传统的骑兵。有趣的是，在 1914 年，英国骑兵在执行侦察、搜寻和掩护撤退方面的表现，要比那些仍然更依恋传统骑兵形式的法国人和德国人好得多。所以，我知道说这话听起来像是异端邪说，但在英国军队中，骑兵其实是 1914 年英国拥有的最先进的部队之一。那么，战壕里的将军们和士兵们是从什么时候开始意识到他们所卷入的战争的真正性质的呢？嗯，从某种意义上说，非常早，因为从一开始伤亡率就惊人地高，远高于他们在布尔战争中经历的水平，事实上也远高于战争爆发前
cavalry is much better at doing the job of recce, scouting and covering the retreat than the French and the Germans, who are still much more wedded to traditional forms of cavalry. So I know it sounds heretical to say it, but in the British army, the cavalry is some of the most advanced troops that Britain has in 1914. And so when do the generals and when do the troops in the trenches begin to realise the nature of the war that they're involved in? Well, in one sense, very early on, because casualties are staggeringly high from the beginning, much higher than they had experienced in the Boer War, and in fact much higher than the planning for replacing troops and indeed for replenishing stocks of shells
对补充部队以及补充炮弹储备的规划所预料的水平。所以到 1914 年 9 月、10 月、11 月左右，没有人再抱有任何幻想了。这是一场非常血腥的战争。加里，真的有人说过“圣诞节前战争就会结束”吗，还是说这只是个神话？确实有各种各样的人说过这话，但这肯定不是军队的某种作战规划假设。
before the war had taken on board. So no one is in any illusion at all by about September, October, November 1914. This is a very bloody war. Gary, had anyone actually said it will be over by Christmas, or is that a myth? Various people did say that, but it certainly wasn't a sort of planning assumption of the army.
毕竟，当基钦拿（Kitchener）于 1914 年 8 月担任陆军大臣时，他立即宣布这场战争将至少持续三年。是的，德国人也是如此。我的意思是，德国人有很多关于毛奇（Moltke）和其他将军的名言，他们大致说过：嗯，我们希望我们能迅速赢得战争，但如果我们做不到，那将是一场彻头彻尾的噩梦，整个欧洲都将被吞噬，诸如此类。
After all, because when Kitchener becomes Secretary of State for War in August 1914, he immediately announces this war's going to last at least three years. Yeah, and the Germans too. I mean, the Germans, there's lots of quotes on it from Moltke and the other generals who sort of say, well, we hope we're going to win it quickly, but if we don't, it's going to be an absolute nightmare and all Europe will be consumed and all this.
嗯，事实上，老毛奇在 19 世纪 90 年代晚年时曾说过一句名言。所以德国人参加战争时，确实把一切都押在速战速决上。而当事情没有按计划发生时，他们想：好吧，我们现在该怎么办？是的。他们随后不得不即兴采用一种长期化的战争形态，当然，他们也确实做到了，
Well, in fact, it's Moltke the Elder who famously says something that I think in the 1890s at the end of his life. So the Germans actually come into the war really staking everything on a quick win. And when it doesn't happen, they think, well, what are we going to do now? Yeah. They then have to improvise a prolonged form of warfare, which of course they do, you know,
在某种程度上可以说是相当成功的。他们让战争又持续了四年。但是，当他们开始意识到战争将陷入僵局、陷入可怕的血腥僵局时，难道就没有人试图达成和平协议吗？事实上，我马上要暴露出我的无知了，我要说的是，最近出版的一本书声称，在 1915 年、1916 年曾有过非常认真的和平谈判尝试。我记不清作者的名字了，而且我也没读过这本书。所以除此之外，我无可奉告。欢迎来到我们的播客。我听过你的很多播客。我只想说，我的看法是，在西方很难看到怎么可能存在妥协的和平，因为那需要德国人做出妥协。
up to a point quite successfully. They keep the war going for another four years. But there's no attempt at this when they start to realise that, you know, it's going to be a deadlock, a horribly bloody deadlock. There's no attempt to kind of arrive at a peace? fact, I'm about to reveal my complete numptiness by saying a book has been published very recently arguing there was a very serious attempt to negotiate peace in 1950, 1916. I can't remember the name of the author and I haven't read the book. So beyond that, I can't comment. Welcome to our podcast. I've listened to many of your podcasts. All I would say is that my take on it is it's difficult to see how there could be a compromise piece in the West because it would involve the Germans compromising.
据我所见，他们从来不准备放弃西方的领土，尽管这样做显然对他们有利。例如，在 1917 年底，当他们实际上已经将俄国打垮、令其退出了战争之后。德国人赢得了第一次世界大战的第一部分，也就是针对俄国的战争。在那时，如果他们从战场走向谈判桌，我深信他们本可以达成一项非常有利的和平协议——比如归还在西方征服的所有土地，而你依然赢了，你拥有了整个俄罗斯帝国可供开发和利用。德国人选择不这么做。他们决定在西方发动进攻以孤注一掷。当然，最终，这反而导致了他们的垮台。所以我没读过这本书，因此无法对这个论点发表评论。但实际上，根据我对证据的解读，
And as far as I can see, they were never prepared to abandon territory in the West, even though it clearly would have been in their advantage to do so. So, for example, at the end of 1917, when they have knocked effectively, they've knocked Russia off the wall. The Germans win the First World War war part one which is against russia at that point had they come they had they sort of moved from the battlefield to the negotiating table i'm pretty sure they could have come up with a very favorable piece as in give back all the stuff they conquered in the west and you've still won you've got all of of the Russian Empire to exploit and to build upon. The Germans choose not to do that. They decide they're going to go for broke by attacking in the West. And of course, in the end, that actually brings them down. So I haven't read the book, so I can't comment on the argument. But actually, for my reading of the evidence,
妥协的空间非常小，因为德国人根本不准备做出那些妥协。而且法国人眼看着德国人占据着他们的领土，他们凭什么要妥协？是的。而且，汤姆，我今天也在想这件事，因为我知道这会被提出来。这有点像我们和安德烈亚·普雷斯顿（Andrea Preston）一起制作的关于越南的播客，探讨美国人为什么持续投入。我的意思是，在政治上，我认为对于战争来说，当你加入时，你就会全力以赴，然后你会说：嗯，这对于我们的国家荣誉和国家生存至关重要。在一两年之后，这就变得很难再说：你知道吗，其实这并非绝对必要，我们大可以做个交易。不仅因为这样做等于背叛——实际上是背叛了所有已经牺牲的人以及所有的烈士家属，你曾对他们说过，他们的死
there's very little scope for compromise because the Germans are simply not prepared to make those compromises. And the French have got the Germans sitting on their territory. Why should they compromise? Yeah. And also, Tom, I was thinking about this today because I knew this would come up. It's a bit like our Vietnam podcast that we did with Andrea Preston about why the Americans kept on with the commitment. I mean, politically, I think with wars, when you go in, you go all in and you sort of say, well, this is essential for our national honour and for our national survival. And it becomes very difficult then after a year or two years to say, you know what, actually, it's not really essential. We can just do a deal. I mean, not least because you're betraying, you're effectively betraying everybody who's already died and all the bereaved to whom you have said it was absolutely essential
绝对是至关重要的，而我们现在致力于赢得这场战争。而且，加里对此会比我了解得得多：如果你读一读士兵们自己的言论，比如英国士兵，他们经常会说：嗯，我决心——你知道的，我们必须完成任务，我们卷入这场战争是有原因的——你知道的，他们当中有很多人非常爱国，他们想要取胜。完全赞同。如果我可以插进一本我记得书名的书，我的朋友迈克·尼伯格（Mike Nyberg）写的，他是美国一位非常杰出的第一次世界大战史学家，书名叫《复仇之舞》（Dance of the Furies）。他认为，实际上在 1914 年 8 月，并不是那种强烈的仇恨驱使欧洲人民走向战争的。
that they died and we are now committed to winning the war and actually gary will know this much better than me if you read what the soldiers themselves were saying like the british soldiers for example they would often say well i'm determined you know we have to finish the job we're in this for a reason you know lots of lots of them were very patriotic and they wanted to win. Absolutely. If I could chuck in the name of a book I can remember the title of, by my friend Mike Nyberg, a very distinguished American historian of the First World War, Dance of the Furies. He argues that actually there wasn't a great deal of hatred which propelled the peoples of Europe into war in August
但在战争爆发之后，是的，那种仇恨确实累积了起来，尤其是由于巨大的伤亡。这就变成了一个问题：难道你要通过达成妥协的和平来背叛那些已经牺牲的人吗？那么，仇恨在战壕里还是在后方家乡更为根深蒂固？实际上，往往是在后方家乡。有一种带点伤感的观点，认为战壕里的所有人彼此钦佩，他们都是同病相怜的人。这种成分确实有一些。但我认为，也有很多个体的仇恨，
1914. But after war broke out, yes, that hatred did pile up, not least because of the vast losses. And it becomes, you know, are you going to betray the people who have died already by making compromised peace? And where is the hatred most visceral, in the trenches or back home? It tends to be on the home fronts, actually. There's a sort of a bit of a sort of sentimental idea that all the men in the trenches admired each other. They were all fellow sufferers. There's certainly a bit of that. There's also a lot of, I think, individual hatred
1914年。但战争爆发后，是的，这种仇恨确实积累起来了，很大程度上是因为巨大的伤亡。这就变成了一个问题：你是否会通过达成妥协的和解来背叛那些已经牺牲的人？仇恨最强烈的究竟是在战壕里，还是在后方？实际上，它往往存在于后方。有一种有点感伤的想法，认为战壕里的所有人都互相钦佩，他们都是难兄难弟。这当然有一点。但我也认为，其中包含着很多个人仇恨
of shooting prisoners out of hand, of failing to take prisoners in the first place. I wouldn't overstress it, but it does tend to be on the home front that you get the real demagogues in Britain, France, Germany, and elsewhere kicking up this fuss. But it does feed into a total war mentality.
比如不分青红皂白地枪杀俘虏，或者一开始就不抓俘虏。我不想过分强调这一点，但在英国、法国、德国和其他地方，煽起这种狂热的往往是后方的真正煽动者。但这确实助长了总体战的心态。
And once you have turned that on, it is very difficult to turn it off again. Right. So on the topic of the experience of the soldiers in the trenches, we had loads of questions about this. Sure. And we began with Wilfred Owen, and that's the kind of conventional sense,
一旦你开启了这种心态，就很难再把它关掉了。没错。那么关于战壕里士兵经历的话题，我们收到了大量这方面的问题。当然。我们从威尔弗雷德·欧文开始，那是一种传统的感觉
is that it's all slaughter, blood, horror, rats, gangrene, whatever. But we've got a question from Mark Brooks. What do you think of the view proposed by Neil Ferguson that many soldiers actually enjoyed their wartime experience? And from Bariga, or Barija, many historians who interviewed First World War infantry veterans say the survivors never talked of the horrors of the trenches but more of mateship and comradeship um yeah did you know what what was it was war hell or was it actually okay people enjoy it I think a very few people actually enjoyed the war in a sense they liked the killing
那就是全都是屠杀、鲜血、恐怖、老鼠、坏疽等等。但我们收到了马克·布鲁克斯的一个问题。你如何看待尼尔·弗格森提出的观点，即许多士兵实际上很享受他们的战时经历？还有来自巴里加或巴里加的观点，许多采访过第一次世界大战步兵老兵的历史学家说，幸存者从不谈论战壕里的恐怖，更多的是谈论战友情谊。嗯，你知道吗，战争到底是地狱，还是其实还行，人们很享受？我认为极少数人真正喜欢战争，那种喜欢杀戮的感觉
and the violence. Hitler of course, famous example of that, Ernst Jünger, Storm of Steel and all the rest of it and the British equivalents. I mean interestingly Siegfried Sassoon was known as Mad Jack within the regiment because he was a suicidally brave officer so you could actually have very ambiguous views about the war. You could actually enjoy it and still hate it in other ways. In a broader sense, I think many men did. Again, enjoys putting it too strongly, but actually they didn't mind the war, at least military experience, and all sorts of reasons for this uh if if you are poor on the margins of society the army will feed you three times a day and give you a stout pair of boots it comes up at that sort of simple level if you are a city clerk an incredibly boring job in london you suddenly are out out out in the fresh air training with your mates and all the rest of it of course once
和暴力。希特勒当然是一个著名的例子，还有恩斯特·容格的《钢铁风暴》以及其他所有人和英国的同类人物。有趣的是，西格弗里德·萨松在团里被称为“疯子杰克”，因为他是一个具有自杀式勇敢精神的军官，所以你实际上对战争有非常矛盾的看法。你可能实际上很享受它，但在其他方面又讨厌它。从更广泛的意义上说，我认为许多人确实如此。同样，说“享受”有点太强烈了，但实际上他们并不介意这场战争，至少是军事经历，这有各种各样的原因。嗯，如果你是社会边缘的穷人，军队一天会喂你三次饭，发给你一双结实的靴子，这就是那种简单层面的原因。如果你是伦敦的一名城市职员，做着一份极其无聊的工作，你突然来到了新鲜空气中，和你的战友一起训练等等。当然，一旦
you get to western front it's different and all the rest of it. Of course, once you get to the Western Front, it's different and all the rest of it. But people do have very mixed and ambiguous responses to the war. I actually interviewed a few Great War veterans. I was in my 20s in the early 80s doing post-grad degrees. And I didn't find any of them who really said, oh, the war was terrible, everybody hated it.
你到了西线，情况就不同了，诸如此类。当然，一旦你到了西线，情况就不同了，诸如此类。但人们对战争的反应确实非常复杂和矛盾。我实际上采访过几位伟大的战争老兵。我在80年代初二十多岁的时候正在攻读研究生学位。我发现他们中没有一个人真正说，哦，战争太可怕了，所有人都讨厌它。
Many of them had a much more nuanced view. Quite a number actually dismissed what we would now call the Blackadder view, of course, it's slightly before Blackadder, as simply, well, you know, okay, it's a bit of knockabout fun. And in the same way, various work has been done on veterans who saw, oh, what a Lovely War, both the play and the film in the 1960s.
他们中的许多人有更加微妙的看法。相当多的人实际上驳斥了我们现在所说的“黑爵士”观点——当然这比《黑爵士》稍早一些——认为这简直就是，好吧，你知道的，这有点像打闹的乐趣。以同样的方式，人们对那些看过20世纪60年代戏剧和电影《多可爱的战争》的老兵进行过各种研究。
And some of them really enjoyed it because they're actually singing the songs of the trenches they remembered, but they rejected the overall message. Yeah, I've heard that story. Isn't there a story about a group of veterans who go on a trip to see the play or something? And at the interval, they're all kind of singing the songs and they're chatting. Oh, do you remember when that bloke had his head blown off? It's kind of these sorts of anecdotes, which in a way is not altogether surprising, is it?
他们中的一些人真的很喜欢它，因为他们实际上在唱他们记得的战壕歌曲，但他们拒绝接受其整体信息。是的，我听说过这个故事。难道不是有一个故事说，有一群老兵去旅行看这出戏或其他什么？在幕间休息时，他们都在唱歌聊天。哦，你还记得那个家伙脑袋被炸飞的时候吗？这种轶事在某种程度上并不是完全令人惊讶的，不是吗？
Because am I not right in thinking that if you're on the Western Front, certainly if you're a British soldier, you don't actually spend that much time in the trench at the front. You spend a lot of time behind the trenches, don't you? Absolutely, you do. The idea that soldiers arrived in France in August 1914 and stood up to their waists in mud until November 1918 is simply untrue. In the classic period of trench warfare, in 19 in 1916 1917 there was a set period of time you might spend four days in the front line four days in the in the support line four days in reserve in other words behind the lines and how much leave would you get uh for the ordinary soldier actually
因为我没记错的话，如果你在西线，当然如果你是一个英国士兵，你实际上并没有花那么多时间在前线的战壕里。你花了很多时间在战壕后面，不是吗？绝对是的，你确实如此。士兵们在1914年8月到达法国，并在齐腰深的泥浆中一直站到1918年11月的想法完全是不真实的。在战壕战的经典时期，在1916年、1917年，有一个固定的时间段，你可能会在火线度过四天，在支援线度过四天，在预备队度过四天，换句话说，在后方。对于普通士兵来说，你会得到多少休假呢？
not not very much uh you might get a couple of weeks every year for officers it's more than that but there was also quite a lot of leisure time building. I mean, it sounds absolutely bizarre to us, but soldiers were sent off to the seaside to do some paddling and sandcastle building. Awful lot of football and cricket and other games are played behind the front. The Army sees sport as being really important as training, as building esprit de corps, and basically as recreation. I don't know if you remember, you've seen the Monocle Mutineer TV series from the 1980s. Now, historically, it's a complete travesty. But some bits of it, they got very right, largely because they relied, I think it was Jack, I can't remember who wrote it, but the writer actually, I think,
其实不多。你每年可能会得到几个星期的假。对于军官来说，时间要多一些，但也有相当多的时间用来搞建设。我的意思是，这听觉对我们来说绝对是不可思议的，但士兵们被派往海边去涉水和建造沙堡。前线后面进行了大量的足球、板球和其他比赛。军队认为体育作为训练、建立军团精神以及基本上作为娱乐非常重要。我不知道你是否还记得，你看过20世纪80年代的电视剧《单片眼镜叛变者》。现在，从历史上看，这是一场彻底的滑稽剧。但其中的某些部分，他们做得非常对，很大程度上是因为他们依靠——我想是杰克，我不记得是谁写的了——但这位作家实际上，我认为
relied very heavily on some reliable sources. And there's one great one in which they have a series of monologues given by soldiers, which were typical things you would hear at concerts behind the lines. Now, given the sort of the culture of Britain at the time in which, you know, the music hall was really important and people made their own entertainment, they would gather around the piano and have sing songs. You get lots and lots of this sort of stuff. And all of this actually very mundane stuff was really important in keeping up morale. And I actually did my PhD work on this sort of stuff.
非常严重地依赖一些可靠的信源。有一个很棒的片段，其中包含了一系列由士兵发表的独白，这些都是你在后方音乐会上经常听到的典型内容。鉴于当时英国的文化，音乐厅非常重要，人们自己制造娱乐，他们会聚集在钢琴周围唱民歌。你会听到大量这样那样的东西。所有这些实际上非常世俗的东西对于保持士气非常重要。我实际上围绕这类东西做了我的博士论文。
And I was actually quite surprised by, you know, it doesn't tend to be, you know, very heroic actions that keep men going. It's, are you playing football are you getting a letter from the missus at home uh you know is is there a decent ration of tobacco can you get hold of some some decent english beer as opposed to french mark it's that sort of sort of thing that keeps people morale up and and that question about the beer that point about the beer um sy james has a question about how similar or different were the experiences of the different kind of troops now am i not right in thinking that when british when people used to capture for example the german trenches they would say oh my god the german
我实际上对一件事感到相当惊讶，你知道，促使人们坚持下去的往往不是什么非常英勇的行动。而是，你在踢足球吗？你有没有收到家里太太的信？你知道，是否有体面的烟草配比？你能弄到一些像样的英国啤酒而不是法国劣质啤酒吗？正是这类事情保持了人们的士气，关于啤酒的那个问题，詹姆斯先生有一个关于不同部队的经历有多么相似或不同的问题。现在，我没记错的话，当英国人过去占领例如德国人的战壕时，他们会说，哦，天哪，德国人的
trenches are fantastic you know they live in five-star luxury compared with us so were they sort of very different experiences of the different combatants uh they, but you must always take into consideration the rampant anti-foreigner prejudices which crop up. So whenever the British take over French trenches, they're dirty, they're unkempt, because they're French. I mean, whether they are or not, it's another matter. You'd expect that though, right? Absolutely. I mean, whether they are or not, it's another matter, but you see that time after time. With the German trenches, it is a bit different for a very interesting strategic reason. The Germans having captured their ground in the Western Front until March 1918, certainly against the British, they're not really seeking to advance. They are there for the long haul.
战壕太棒了，你知道的，与我们相比，他们过着五星级的奢华生活。那么不同参战者的经历是不是很不相同呢？是的，但是你必须总是把那些无处不在的疯狂的反外国人偏见考虑在内。因此，每当英国人接管法国战壕时，他们都会觉得这些战壕又脏又乱，因为它们是法国人的。我的意思是，不管它们是不是那样，那是另一回事。不过你也会预料到这一点，对吧？完全是的。我的意思是，不管它们是不是那样，那是另一回事，但你会一次又一次地看到这种情况。对于德国战壕来说，由于一个非常有趣的战略原因，情况有点不同。德国人自从在西线占领了他们的阵地直到1918年3月，至少在对抗英国人时，他们并不是真正寻求推进。他们是为了长久驻扎在那里。
They are. So therefore, they're happy to build deeper trenches than the British to make them more livable in because people could be there for a long time. With the British, they're only ever a temporary expedient, at least in theory, because you're going to be leaving those trenches and capturing the ones in front of you. And so actually, there is some truth in the idea that German trenches tend to be deeper. They tend to be more comfortable than the British ones. But of course, there is a fair amount of, you know, scuttle about going about these things, these rumors about, you know, the Germans, oh, Germans have women in their trenches. Showers.
他们确实如此。因此，他们很高兴建造比英国人更深的战壕，使其更适合居住，因为人们可能会在那里待很长时间。对于英国人来说，它们永远只是权宜之计，至少在理论上是这样，因为你要离开这些战壕去占领你面前的战壕。因此，德国人的战壕往往更深，这种观点确实有一定道理。它们往往比英国人的战壕更舒适。但当然，关于这些事情也有相当多的流言蜚语，关于德国人的谣言，哦，德国人战壕里有女人。淋浴设施。
Absolutely, all that sort of stuff. So, Tom, there's a question here that I put in there that I got off Twitter just to appeal to you. And I'm amazed you haven't asked it yet. Is this one from Stev Hepp? It is Stev Hepp. Are you not going to ask Stev Hepp's question? Well, it's been staring out at me
绝对的，诸如此类。所以，汤姆，这里有一个问题，我把它放进去，我是从推特上找来的，只是为了吸引你。我很惊讶你居然还没问。这是斯蒂夫·赫普提出的吗？确实是斯蒂夫·赫普。你难道不打算问斯蒂夫·赫普的问题吗？好吧，它一直盯着我看
and I've been heroically resisting it. Go on, go on, indulge yourself. There was a pause there and I thought, should I dive in? And I didn't. And then you served it up to me. Okay, so this is from Steve Hepp, who is a friend of the show,
而我一直在英勇地抵抗它。说吧，说吧，放纵一下自己吧。刚才停顿了一下，我想，我应该跳进去吗？我没有。然后你把它端到了我面前。好吧，这是史蒂夫·赫普提出的，他是节目的朋友
sent in lots of fascinating questions. And Gary, I know you'll be interested in this question. On the topic of morale and how people's feelings in the trench, this is on an aspect that often I think gets overlooked, but obviously I also think is important. Of course, you would say that. Devotion to and visions of St. Therese of Lisieux were a widespread phenomenon on the Western front, and Wilfred Owen's war poetry is fused with Christian imagery.
发来了很多精彩的问题。加里，我知道你会对这个问题感兴趣。关于士气以及人们在战壕中的感受这个话题，这往往是我认为经常被忽视的一个方面，但显然我也认为它很重要。你当然会这么说。对利雪的圣特蕾莎的奉献和幻象是西线普遍存在的现象，威尔弗雷德·欧文的战争诗歌融合了基督教意象。
Did faith, Christian faith, I guess, specifically, play an important role in the psychology of frontline soldiers? Well, I'm completely surprised, of course, you've asked me a question about Christianity, Tom. I didn't see that coming at all. I know, it's actually literally a bombshell. Can I just briefly, before I answer, it's a really good question, say something about Wilfred Owen. I meant to say that after you said this poem at the beginning. That's actually not entirely typical of Owen's view of the war. After all, he is a man who was decorated for gallantry and actually killed in a really excellent piece of low-level leadership
信仰，我想特别是基督教信仰，在前线士兵的心理中扮演了重要角色吗？嗯，我完全感到惊讶，你竟然问了我一个关于基督教的问题，汤姆。我一点也没有预见到这一点。我知道，这实际上真的是一枚重磅炸弹。在我回答之前，能不能简短地说一下，这是一个非常好的问题，说点关于威尔弗雷德·欧文的事情。我本打算在你开始时念了这首诗之后说这番话的。这其实并不完全代表欧文对战争的看法。毕竟，他是一个因英勇作战而受到表彰的人，并且实际上是在一次非常出色的低层领导行动中牺牲的
in November... It's crossing the canal, wasn't it? Yes, it's crossing the canal, wasn't it? Yes, it's crossing the canal. And what's always forgotten, almost always forgotten, is that the 4th of November 1918 is the last great British victory on the Western Front. And the reason it's the last great British victory on the Western Front is it played a large role
在11月……那是过运河，对吧？是的，那是过运河，对吧？是的，那是过运河。人们总是忘记、几乎总是忘记的是，1918年11月4日是西线最后一次伟大的英国胜利。它之所以是西线最后一次伟大的英国胜利，是因为它在很大程度上
in breaking the German high command's will to fight on any longer. So the idea he's killed just before the end of the war, wasn't it a tragedy? Well, yes, it was a tragedy that this man was died. Was it a tragedy in the sense of completely futile and senseless? No, it wasn't. Britain being Britain,
打破了德国最高指挥部继续战斗下去的意志。所以，认为他在战争结束前不久被杀，难道不是一个悲剧吗？好吧，是的，这个人死了是一个悲剧。但在完全徒劳和毫无意义的意义上，它是一个悲剧吗？不，它不是。英国就是英国
we've completely forgotten the victory of the 4th of November 1918. But nonetheless, it is one of the most significant British military victories of the First World War. And so I think we need to see, oh, it's like other soldiers, actually had quite an ambiguous view about the war. To latch on to the pity of war and the rest of it actually is not to see the whole picture. Right, so not a pointless death. Not a pointless death. In military terms. It is not in a military sense, and I would argue it is not in the broader sense, because I think the First World War is a war that was forced upon britain and britain actually had to win but that's been come back
我们完全忘记了1918年11月4日的胜利。但尽管如此，它仍然是第一次世界大战中英国最重大的军事胜利之一。因此，我认为我们需要看到，哦，就像其他士兵一样，其实对战争有着相当矛盾的看法。抓住战争的残酷以及其他一切不放，实际上并没有看到事情的全貌。对，所以不是毫无意义的死亡。不是毫无意义的死亡。从军事术语上讲。从军事意义上讲不是，而且我认为从更广泛的意义上讲也不是，因为我认为第一次世界大战是一场强加给英国的战争，英国实际上必须赢得这场战争，但这会在后面讲到
i think we should come to that after the break but if we could just look specifically on the on the issue of faith in the trenches right i've got a an admission to make here that when i was writing my phd on british morale uh in the early 90s i almost entirely overlooked christianity as a factor uh which is daft, actually, because I was a paid-up Christian member of the C of E and all the rest of it. But actually, it simply did not feature very highly in the literature of the time. In recent years, however, it has come back with a vengeance. There's a lot of really excellent stuff about faith and morale in the First World War by, for example, my former colleague at the University
我想我们应该在休息后谈谈这个，但如果我们能具体看看战壕里的信仰问题，好吧，我在这里得承认一件事：当我在90年代初撰写关于英国士气的博士论文时，我几乎完全忽视了基督教作为一个因素，这其实很荒谬，因为我是一个名册上的英国国教会基督徒等等。但实际上，它在当时的文献中并不怎么显眼。然而，近年来，它以雷霆万年之势卷土重来。关于第一次世界大战中的信仰和士气，有许多非常出色的研究，例如我的前伯明翰大学同事
of Birmingham, Michael Snape, by Alex Watson at Goldsmiths, and various other people. And I think it is really important. Now, I think that the number of people who were active practicing Christians, and it had a really impact on their morale, are fairly small, but in the sense of diffusive Christianity, that everybody in Britain at that time pretty well had some sort of belief however vague and they certainly signed up to a a Christian worldview it is really very significant and the war was sold at some level as a crusade I think it was understood at some level as a crusade and even at at the micro level, going to church services, I mean, church parades are never very popular, except on the eve of battle. Actually, they tend to be informal, voluntary
迈克尔·斯内普，金史密斯的亚历克斯·沃森，以及其他各种人。我认为这真的很重要。现在，我认为积极践行基督教信仰的人数及其对他们士气产生真正影响的人数相当少，但在基督教扩散的意义上，当时英国的每个人几乎都拥有某种信仰，无论多么模糊，他们肯定都认同一种基督教世界观，这确实非常重要。这场战争在某种程度上被当作十字军东征来兜售，我认为它在某种程度上被理解为一场十字军东征，甚至在微观层面上，去参加礼拜，我的意思是，教堂阅兵从来都不怎么受欢迎，除了在战役前夕。实际上，它们往往是非正式的、自愿的
services. And soldiers did get an awful lot out of them. And indeed, the people at home got a lot of solace, I think, through faith. Now, some of this went off at slightly strange angles of course the first world war sees a massive revival of spiritualism uh because as people seek for answers outside the established balance of christianity and to contact the dead and all the rest of it arthur conan doyle of course that the fate that the uh the author of most famously rational detective sherlock holmes buys into this in a really big way. But what I would say in general terms is that historians now, myself included, would now see faith, and specifically Christian faith of various degrees, how orthodox or not, another matter, has a really important role in maintaining soldiers' morale. The same is also true, I think, in Germany and to some extent in
服务。士兵们确实从宗教信仰中获得了极大的慰藉。当然，国内的人民我认为也通过信仰得到了很大的精神安抚。现在，其中一些信仰走上了一些略微奇怪的道路。当然，第一次世界大战见证了精神主义的大规模复兴，嗯，因为人们在基督教既定平衡之外寻求答案，并试图与死者联系等等。亚瑟·柯南·道尔，当然，最著名的理性侦探歇洛克·福尔摩斯的创造者，对这一点深信不疑。但我想说的是，总的来说，历史学家现在——包括我自己在内——会认为信仰，特别是不同程度的基督教信仰——无论它是否正统，那是另一回事——在维持士兵士气方面发挥了真正重要的作用。我认为，在德国也是如此，在某种程度上在
France, although I don't have any expertise in those two armies. And Dominic, of course, the single most influential text to come out of the First World War was written by a very committed Christian. Gerard Tolkien, of course. Yes. And I think on that note, we should go to a quick break. And then we come back, Gary, perhaps we could talk the the strategy and the generalship and whether it was all a waste of time or whether it served served a purpose brilliant see you after the break I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus
法国也是如此，尽管我对这两支军队没有专门的研究。多米尼克，当然，一战中诞生最具影响力的作品是由一位非常虔诚的基督徒写的，当然就是J·R·R·托尔金。是的。我想顺着这个话题，我们应该休息一下。休息回来后，加里，也许我们可以谈谈战略和将领指挥，以及这一切究竟是不是在浪费时间，还是说它确实达到了某种目的。太棒了，休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们联手主持《这一切都是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的娱乐圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，并告诉大家它是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家福利
episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are with Professor Gary Sheffield, author of Forgotten Victory, expert on the Western Front. And we're about to get into something that I know he's very enthusiastic about. So we have a question from Stephen, which I'm sure you will welcome. Is the lions led by donkeys analysis unfair? So this is the idea that the generals of this kind of pack of
节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的剩余部分》（The Rest Is History）。我们邀请到了《遗忘的胜利》一书的作者、西线专家加里·谢菲尔德教授。我们即将探讨一个我知道他非常热衷的话题。因此，我们有一个来自斯蒂芬的问题，我确信你会欢迎这个问题。由驴子领导的狮子这种分析是否不公平？所以这个观点认为，这场战争中的将军们是一群
you know upper class twits and competent buffoons and the soldiers are heroic lions who have been betrayed and sacrificed and slaughtered in their in their thousands um and it's all the general's fault and i know you have very strong views about this the answer is no. Next question, please. Now, OK, it's to go back a bit. The whole lines led by donkeys thing is something which emerged really during the 1930s in a fully fledged form. You can see elements of that during the war itself, although not not very strongly out of the 1920s. But generally speaking, until Phil Marshall, Sir Douglas Hague, Earl Hague as he becomes, dies in early 1928, or was it 29? I've written a biography. I really ought to remember that. Anyway, sorry.
你知道的，上流社会的傻瓜和无能的庸才，而士兵们则是英勇的狮子，他们被背叛、牺牲，成千上万地被屠杀……这一切都是将军们的错。我知道你对此有非常强烈的看法。答案是：不。下一个问题，请。好了，好吧，稍微回溯一下。整套由驴子领导的狮子这种说法，是在20世纪30年代才真正以成熟的形式出现的。你可以在战争本身期间看到这种说道的萌芽，尽管在20年代并不十分明显。但总的来说，直到陆军元帅道格拉斯·海格爵士（后来成为海格伯爵）于1928年初去世——或者那是29年？我写过一本传记，我真该记住这个日期的。总之，抱歉。
But he dies. If only we had a biographer of Douglas Hague. If only. I'm sorry. I had one as complete mental blackouts, not for the first time. Hague dies at the end of the 20s. Let's just fudge it like that and coincidentally it actually um coincides with what has become known as beginning of the great war books boom this outpouring of disillusioned uh war memoirs
但他去世了。要是我们有一位道格拉斯·海格的传记作家就好了。要是真有就好了。对不起，我刚才脑子里一片空白，这已经不是第一次了。海格在20年代末去世。我们就这么含糊过去吧，巧合的是，这实际上……它恰好符合后来被称为伟大战争书籍热潮（great war books boom）的开始，也就是充满幻灭感的……
uh novels rediscovery of poetry, people like Owen, for example. And this sort of sees the floodgates open and there's a huge backlash against the generals, the war, and this basic idea that it was a war worth fighting. And is this being sharpened by events in the 30s? And the sense that Germany, you know, there's going to be another war? It becomes sharper. So the course actually predates that.
战争回忆录、小说的大量涌现，以及对诗歌的重新发现，例如欧文这样的人。这就像是打开了闸门，对将军们、对战争、以及对这是一场值得一战的基本信念，产生了巨大的强烈反弹。这种情绪是否被30年代的事件所加剧了？并且让人觉得德国……你知道的，还会有另一场战争？这种情绪变得更加尖锐了。所以这种进程实际上早于那个时期。
I think in some ways it's quite a natural breaking point. We can see a similar sort of thing with Vietnam in the late 70s and early 80s. There's a backlash. The deer hunt and all the rest of it. I think that the real revulsion actually is not against the war itself, or at least if you read many of the books, it's not against the war itself. It's actually against the peace that emerged from the war itself uh or at least if you read many of the books it's not against the war itself it's actually against the peace that emerged from the war because if they were sold during the war with the idea that is that the war you know it's gonna be a land fit for heroes to live in
我认为在某些方面这是一个相当自然的转折点。我们在70年代末和80年代初的越南战争中也能看到类似的情况。出现了一种强烈的反弹。比如《猎鹿人》和其他种种。我认为真正的反感实际上并不是针对战争本身，或者至少如果你读了很多书，它不是针对战争本身的。它实际上是针对从战争中诞生的和平……或者至少如果你读了很多书，它不是针对战争本身的，它实际上是针对从战争中诞生的和平。因为如果在战争期间向他们灌输的理念是，战争，你知道的，将会让这里成为一个适合英雄居住的国度，
the land that soldiers can't ex-soldiers come back to in the 20s is actually quite hard. Economically, Britain is going through problems. The British Empire is clearly, you know, on the skids to some extent. And Germany, having been defeated, then emerges in the 20s as a democratic state, didn't last for very long. And there is a sense that why did we bother to fight this conflict? However, if you read the actual, if you read much of the disillusioned material, it's really not that the war wasn't worth fighting that people are saying. It's actually, well, what happened at the end of it? Was it all worth it? And I should actually say that this period of massive disillusionment, which of course brings at the end of it was it all worth it and i should actually say that this period of of massive dissolution which of course brings about the emergence of pacifism really is the only time in british history as a serious political force actually is quite short-lived
那么在20世纪20年代，士兵们返回的这片土地其实相当艰难。从经济上讲，英国正在经历问题。大英帝国显然……你知道的，在某种程度上正在走下坡路。而德国在被击败后，在20年代作为一个民主国家崛起，虽然没有持续多久。人们有一种感觉：我们为什么要费力去打这场冲突？然而，如果你阅读实际的材料，如果你读了很多充满幻灭感的资料，人们真正说的并不是这场战争不值得去打。实际上是，战争结束时发生了什么？这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻灭的时期——当然，它带来了……这一切真的值得吗？我其实应该说，这段大规模幻迈入和平主义的诞生——实际上是英国历史上唯一一个作为严肃政治力量存在且相当短暂的时期，
and it's quite quite shallow uh many of the people who was uh public school boys in the late 20s and early 30s are you know joining the peace pled union and rest of it are there as infantry officers in the in the army 1939 1940 uh michael howard professor sir michael howard who died only about about two years ago uh became the greatest british military historian of the 20th century, wrote very revealingly about how he was carried away as a school by Wellington in the 30s by these ideas. And of course, he ends up as an officer in the Coldstream Guards, winning the MC and becoming a great military historian, or the rest of it. But what this does do, I think, is actually have a major impact, which lasts long beyond the period of the 30s, about the way that the First World War is viewed. And the second major event, I think,
而且相当肤浅。许多在20年代末和30年代是公学男孩的人，你知道的，加入了和平宣誓联盟（Peace Pledge Union）及其他组织，但到了1939年、1940年，他们却作为步兵军官加入了军队。迈克尔·霍华德教授——迈克尔·霍华德爵士，在两年前左右去世——成为了20世纪最伟大的英国军事历史学家。他曾非常深刻地写道，30年代他在学校时是如何被这些想法带跑的。当然，他最终成为了冷溪近卫团的一名军官，赢得了军功十字勋章（MC），并成为了一名伟大的军事历史学家，诸如此类。但我觉得，这确实产生了一个重大影响，这个影响远远超出了30年代的范畴，并影响了人们看待第一次世界大战的方式。我认为第二个重大事件是，
is the Second World War, which in very crude terms, the Second World War from the British point of view is a good war. The British are obviously wearing the white hats, the Germans are obviously wearing the black hats. In Germans are obviously wearing the black hats. When the First World War, things are much more ambiguous. And seen from 1945, why is Britain fighting Germany? Was the Kaiser really that bad? Was the Kaiser as bad as Hitler? The answer to all this, of course, is no. Well, the Kaiser wasn't as bad as Hitler.
第二次世界大战。用非常粗略的术语来说，从英国的角度来看，二战是一场正义的战争。英国人显然戴着白帽，德国人显然戴着黑帽。德国人显然戴着黑帽。而在一战中，事情要模糊得多。从1945年的角度来看，英国为什么要与德国作战？德皇真的那么坏吗？德皇和希特勒一样坏吗？对这一切的回答，当然是否定的。好吧，德皇没有希特勒那么坏。
But that ignores the really desperate threat that Imperial Germany posed to Britain, to the British Empire, which of course is extremely important in people's thinking in the First World War, to the stability of Europe, and I would argue to the existence of liberal democracy of Europe in 1914. So by being branched out of context, all of this suddenly, the First World War no longer makes sense. And the third major thing, I think, is what happens in the 1960s is CND, the Cold War on Nuclear Weapons,
但这忽视了德意志帝国对英国、对大英帝国（这在第一次世界大战人们的思考中当然极其重要）、对欧洲稳定构成的真正绝望的威胁，而且我认为，这也威胁到了1914年欧洲自由民主的存在。因此，由于脱离了上下文，这一切突然间让第一次世界大战变得毫无意义。我认为第三个重大事件是20世纪60年代发生的反对核裁军运动（CND）和冷战时期的核武器问题，
whereby, I mean, oh, what a lovely war, I think in many ways, is basically projecting Cold War fears of mass deaths onto the First World War and using the First World War as a sort of analog for the Cold War. All of this fuels this sort of backlash against the First World War. And actually, it infects popular television, films, all the rest of it, and loads and loads of popular books,
借此——我的意思是，噢，多么可爱的战争（Oh! What a Lovely War），我认为在许多方面，这基本上是将冷战对大规模死亡的恐惧投射到了第一次世界大战上，并把一战当作冷战的一种类比。所有这一切都助长了这种对第一次世界大战的反弹。事实上，它侵蚀了大众电视、电影以及所有其他媒介，还有许许多多的大众书籍，
possibly on a very long list of terrible books about the First World War. Alan Clarke's The Donkeys, which appears in 1961, is absolutely the worst. But only a year before that, a book by Cyril Falls, who is a combat veteran of the First World War and official historian, appears, which has a very balanced, very modern view of the First World War. John Turrain, the great enfant terrible of British military history, he starts writing at the end of the 1950s, rehabilitating Douglas Haig. So for those who want to read a bit more widely, there is a more balanced view of the First World War around. But it's not really until the 1980s that it starts to get into the academic mainstream extent it ever has, let alone into the public mainstream. Okay, so that sets up two brilliant questions.
这可能列入了一长串关于第一次世界大战的糟糕书籍中。艾伦·克拉克的《驴子们》（The Donkeys）出版于1961年，绝对是最糟糕的一本。但就在前一年，西里尔·福尔斯（Cyril Falls）的一本书出版了，他是一战的战斗老兵兼官方历史学家，这本书对一战有着非常平衡、非常现代的看法。约翰·特兰（John Terraine），英国军事历史界伟大的异端邪说者，他在50年代末开始写作，为道格拉斯·海格平反。因此，对于那些想要更广泛阅读的人来说，身边其实存在着对一战更平衡的看法。但直到20世纪80年代，这种看法才真正进入学术主流（只要它曾经进入过的话），更不用说进入公众主流了。好了，这就铺垫了两个精彩的问题。
One of which is, you know, what are the stakes on the Western Front for both sides? But let's stay focused on the British. And also how effective are the generals on the British and the French side in prosecuting the war? Now, I don't know if you heard our episode on the origins of the First World War. I knew you were going to bring this up, Tom.
其中之一是，你知道的，西线对双方来说利害攸关的是什么？但让我们把焦点放在英国人身上。还有，英国和法国方面的将军们在进行这场战争时的效率如何？现在，我不知道你是否听过我们关于第一次世界大战起源的那期节目。我知道你要把这个提出来，汤姆。
In which Dominic presented a radical thesis that we should have sided with the Germans against the French. So I'm just going to sit back and... Like Switzerland. Yeah. Like the Swiss and watch you two... And everybody loves the Swiss, don't they? Nobody looks at the Swiss.
在节目中，多米尼克提出了一个激进的论点，即我们应该站在德国人一边对抗法国人。所以我现在要做的就是靠在椅背上……就像瑞士一样。是的。就像瑞士人一样，看着你们两个……每个人都喜欢瑞士人，不是吗？没有人会去审视瑞士人。
Nobody thinks of them as smug. I don't mind being smug on a occasion like this. Strangely enough, a number of British soldiers in 1914 actually would have agreed with Dominic's view. Yeah, of course. Because the Germans played football, drank beer and all the rest of it. They're much more like us than the French. But Gary, listeners have heard Dominic's ludicrous views on this.
没有人会觉得他们自命不凡。在这样的场合，我不介意表现得自命不凡。说也奇怪，1914年的许多英国士兵实际上会同意多米尼克的观点。是的，当然。因为德国人踢足球、喝啤酒等等。他们比法国人更像我们。但是加里，听众们已经听过了多米尼克在这方面荒谬的观点。
So give us the measured sensible perspective on what's at stake. Well, it's difficult to be measured on the origins of the First World War. It's also difficult
所以，请给我们一个冷静、明智的视角，来看看究竟是什么生死攸关。好吧，要对第一次世界大战的起源保持冷静是很困难的。要花不到五周的时间来讲述它也很困难。
to spend less than five weeks on it. My take on it actually is a very simple view, perhaps a simplistic view, is that ultimately the triggers for the First World War come from
我对此的看法实际上是一个非常简单的观点，也许是一个过分简化的观点，那就是最终第一次世界大战的导火索来自
Berlin and from Vienna. The Austro-Hungarians, from their perspective, good reasons want to go and sort out the Serbs, which they regard as being an existential threat to the Habsburg Empire. The trouble is the Serbs are, of course uh protected by russia which is allied to france which is has a loose allegiance to to to britain the germans in uh the blank check in early july 1914 effectively say to the austrians we will back whatever you do, knowing full well that that is likely to unleash the dominoes which bring in Russia, which bring in France, which even bring in Britain. So up to the point at which the Austrians attack Serbia on the 23rd of July 1914, the First World War is eminently avoidable, in my view.
柏林和维也纳。奥匈帝国从他们的角度出发，出于充分的理由，想要去收拾塞尔维亚人，他们认为塞尔维亚人对哈布斯堡王朝构成了生存威胁。问题是，塞尔维亚人当然受到了俄罗斯的保护，而俄罗斯与法国结盟，法国与英国有着松散的同盟关系。德国人在1914年7月初开出的空白支票，实际上对奥地利人说：无论你们做什么，我们都会支持，他们心知肚明这很可能会引发多米尼克骨牌效应，把俄罗斯、法国甚至英国都牵扯进来。因此，在1914年7月23日奥地利人进攻塞尔维亚之前，在我看来，第一次世界大战是完全可以避免的。
After that point, it is not, because basically this is starting to bring the great power structures into play. And it's very deliberate decisions on the part of the German and Austrian decision-making elite. Now, no one is completely free of blame in the sense that everybody, to some extent, contributed to the pile of tinder, to the hackneyed phrase, which actually a flame is set to it, and it blows up in the summer of 1914. But it's the Germans, the Austrians, who actually make decisions consciously that they could have chosen not to have made and kick off the war.
在那之后，就无法避免了，因为基本上这开始将大国结构卷入其中。这是德国和奥地利决策精英做出的非常刻意的决定。现在，没有人能完全免除责任，因为在某种程度上，每个人都为那堆引火柴（借用那个陈腐的短语）贡献了一份力，而火星最终点燃了它，并在1914年夏天爆发了。但正是德国人和奥地利人，有意识地做出了他们本可以选择不做的决定，并挑起了战争。
Gary, could I just jump in? Please do. Did you not make the same claim, for example, about Russia? No. No, Dominic. Dominic, this is about the Western Front and you're dragging us around. I'm going to be like Melvin Bragg.
加里，我能插话吗？请便。难道你对俄罗斯没有提出过同样的说法吗？没有。没有，多米尼克。多米尼克，这是关于西线的，而你把我们扯到了别处。我要变得像梅尔文·布拉格（Melvin Bragg）一样了。
Oh, this is shocking. No, I'm really going to have to. This is absolutely shocking. Because this is about the Western Front. So what I really want to know is, Gary, your position as someone who really knows about this. I think we should end the podcast here. No offence, no offence.
噢，这太令人震惊了。不，我真的不得不这么做。这绝对令人震惊。因为这是关于西线的。所以我真正想知道的是，加里，作为对此真正了解的人，你的立场是什么。我想我们应该在这里结束播客。无意冒犯，无意冒犯。
What is at stake for the British and the French in the Western Front? So if the Germans break through and they capture Paris or whatever, what follows? What is at stake? Right, what is at stake? First of all, for the French, now actually we know what the Germans are intending to do
英国人和法国人在西线上面临的利害关系是什么？所以，如果德国人突破防线，占领了巴黎或其他地方，接下来会发生什么？利害关系是什么？好吧，利害关系是什么？首先，对于法国人来说，现在实际上我们知道德国人打算做什么，
because actually they wrote a memorandum in September, so after the war had broken out, about what they will do in the event of the victory they think is going to happen very shortly. Basically, it's to reduce France
因为他们在9月——也就是战争爆发后——写了一份备忘录，关于他们在他们认为很快就会发生的胜利到来时会做什么。基本上，就是要把法国
to a second-class power, to take big chunks of key French industrial land in the north of France. Belgium becomes a German protectorate. Belgium actually is one of the most highly advanced industrialized states in Europe, of course. And in the east, effectively, they create, well, basically what Hitler set out to do in the east 25 years later, minus the conscious genocide, which of course is a very big thing, but nonetheless, it's effectively reduced the Romanov Empire to a series of German client states.
降格为一个二流强国，夺取法国北部关键工业用地的很大一部分土地。比利时将成为德国的保护国。当然，比利时实际上是欧洲高度先进的工业化国家之一。而在东部，实际上他们创建了一个国家，嗯，基本上就是希特勒25年后在东部着手做的事情，去掉了有意识的种族灭绝（当然这是一个非常大的事情），但尽管如此，它实际上是将罗曼诺夫帝国贬为一系列德国的附庸国。
So that completely tips the balance of power in Europe. And a French would have been reduced to the situation, you know, pre-1870, pre-1815. So that stuff with the French sounds great to me, Gary. I'm staying out of this one. For the British, obviously, that has an enormous impact on stability. One of the great tenets of British foreign policy, English foreign policy going back centuries, of course,
这彻底颠覆了欧洲的力量平衡。法国人的处境将被倒退回1870年之前、1815年之前。所以法国人的那些事儿听起来对我挺好的，加里。我置身事外。对于英国人来说，这显然对稳定性产生了巨大的影响。英国外交政策、英国几个世纪以来的外交政策的核心信条之一，当然是
is to maintain a balance of power in Europe and also to keep the low countries specifically in this case belgium free of uh an aggressor particularly an aggressor with a powerful navy which of course germany is and also of course very unfashionable today but the british empire is critically important to british thinking not merely of the british government but actually to the british people and not so much canada because they've got the united states on on its doorstep but australia new zealand uh south africa lots of places actually really scared by the threat not so much what will happen uh if if the germans turn up because you know the germans aren't there in any great strength but actually
维持欧洲的力量平衡，并保持低地国家（特别是本案中的比利时）免受侵略者的侵害，尤其是免受拥有强大海军的侵略者的侵害，而德国正是如此。还有，当然，虽然今天很不时髦，但大英帝国对英国人的思考至关重要，不仅对英国政府，实际上对英国人民也是如此。不是对加拿大，因为加拿大有美国在门前，而是对澳大利亚、新西兰、南非，许多地方其实真的对这种威胁感到恐惧，倒不是因为德国人出现会怎么样（因为德国人在那里并没有什么强大的兵力），而是因为
if the shield of the royal navy is removed so So if I put Australia and New Zealand really worried about Japan, a British ally at this stage, but the Aussies and the Kiwis are not very keen on this. And really their defence rests upon the Royal Navy. Remove Britain, remove the Royal Navy from the board, suddenly everything's up in the air. So for the british as they see it it is an absolute existential threat that everything is going to to to um
如果皇家海军的盾牌被移除了。如果我把澳大利亚和新西兰放在对日本极度担忧的处境下，日本在这个阶段是英国的盟友，但澳大利亚人和新西兰人对此并不是很热心。他们的防务实际上依赖于皇家海军。如果拿掉英国，从棋盘上拿掉皇家海军，一切突然间都悬而未决了。因此，在英国人看来，这是一场绝对的生存威胁，一切都将……
to to to to be up up up okay so the stakes are very high um absolutely so seen in that light what case would you make for the performance of the British military and particularly the high command? I actually don't think you could link the two things, because the ability to end the war by a compromise piece and negotiation, that's actually up at a higher level, at least the British military actually don't have very much say in that at all. The performance of the British military is patchy, to put it mildly i think it's related to having to learn to fight a new style of warfare for the reasons i gave at the very beginning of the program basically they haven't done this sort of stuff before british army before the war is very small it's very experienced but in colonial warfare which only has limited crossover to what they are
悬而未决。好吧，利害关系非常高。绝对是这样。从这个角度来看，你对英国军队尤其是高级指挥部的表现作何评价？我其实认为你不能把这两件事联系起来，因为通过妥协的和平与谈判来结束战争的能力，那其实处于更高的层面，至少英国军队在这一点上根本没有太多发言权。英国军队的表现，委婉地说，是参差不齐的。我认为这与他们不得不学习以一种新的风格进行战争有关，原因我在节目的最初就讲过了，基本上他们以前没有做过这种事情。一战前英国军队非常小，非常有经验，但那是在殖民战争中，而殖民战争与他们在西线上所做的事情只有有限的重合。
doing on on the western front and the if you if you think that the british army sees major combat really for the first time on the somme in july 1916 um yes last but not before but this is brilliant on a major scale it's an army which is largely composed of men who had been civilians 18 months before not terribly well trained and their officers although they don't have quite a lot of experience, not at the level at which they are commanding, and not at the sort of experience that is relevant. And I'm not for one moment going to try and whitewash the mistakes that were made, the lives that were cost and all the rest of it. All I would say is that by the end
而且，如果你认为英国军队在1916年7月的索姆河战役中真正第一次经历重大战斗……是的，之前也有过，但这是第一次大规模的战役。这是一支主要由18个月前还是平民的男子组成的军队，训练不是非常好。他们的军官虽然有一定的经验，但不是在他所指挥的那个级别上，也没有具备相关的经验。我绝不会试图粉饰所犯下的错误、所付出的生命代价等等。我只想说，到战争结束时，
of the war, the learning process has been pretty impressive. And the British Army is by no means flawless, but actually it is highly effective. It is better, I would argue, than the German Army. It is better armed. It's better trained. It's better commanded. It's got higher morale. And all of this means that the victories in 1918, in my view, are the greatest in British military history. Certainly in terms of scale, they're bigger than Wellington's victories. They're bigger than Montgomery's victories. And also, I would argue, in terms of what is at stake.
学习的过程是非常令人印象深刻的。英国军队绝非毫无瑕疵，但实际上它非常高效。我认为它比德国军队更好。它的武装更好。它的训练更好。它的指挥更好。它的士气更高。所有这一切意味着，在我看来，1918年的胜利是英国军事史上最伟大的胜利。当然，就规模而言，它们比威灵顿的胜利还要大。它们比蒙哥马利的胜利还要大。而且我认为，就利害关系而言也是如此。
And one of the problems we have of the Blackadder view, or indeed the photo that you put on Twitter to advertise this podcast. I agree with you, Gary. That was shocking. Well, I wasn't surprised you did it, but it sets up a particular set of assumptions. Now, of course, if the First World War, in fact, going back to the 1920s, had been seen largely through the prism of 1918 and the victories,
我们面临的问题之一，是黑爵士（Blackadder）视角的观点，或者确实是你们放在推特上用来宣传这个播客的照片。我同意你的看法，加里。那太令人震惊了。好吧，你这么做我并不感到意外，但这设定了一套特定的假设。现在，当然，如果第一次世界大战——实际上回溯到20世纪20年代——主要是通过1918年及其胜利的棱镜来看待，
rather than 1916 and the disasters, we would have a very different view of the First World War. And something I and a number of other historians have tried to do over the last few years is simply say, there's more to it than the Somme. It's a lot more complicated than all that. It's very sad, Gary, that people like Tom are trying to undo all the work that you've done. We should just explain. We should say that the photo was a picture of people carrying stretchers through the mud of Passchendaele. Well, this is what I want to ask about. So let me, before we get on to 1918,
而不是通过1916年及其灾难的棱镜，我们对第一次世界大战就会有非常不同的看法。我和其他一些历史学家在过去几年里一直试图做的事情很简单，那就是：除了索姆河，还有更多内容。事情比这要复杂得多。加里，像汤姆这样的人试图抹杀你所做的一切工作，真是太遗憾了。我们应该解释一下。我们应该说，那张照片是一张人们在帕斯尚尔的泥泞中用担架抬人的照片。好吧，这就是我想问的。所以让我在我们进入1918年之前——
and I know you're brilliant on 1918, and I really want to do that, the German offensive and then the Allied counterattack and so on. But if I was, you know, some people who disagree with you would say, and if I'm sort of going to ventriloquise them, they would say, you've leaped pretty quickly from the Somme to 1918, and there's a long period in between where they're making the same mistakes again and again,
我知道你在1918年的问题上非常出色，我真的很想谈那个，比如德国的进攻和盟军的反击等等。但如果我是……你知道的，有些不同意你观点的人会说——如果我在这里代他们发言的话——他们会说，你从索姆河非常快地跳跃到了1918年，而在这中间有一段很长的时期，他们一直在重复犯同样的错误，
and they're not learning from their mistakes. At Pashtun Dale, for example. Is that fair, or do you think that criticism... So, in other words, you know, they keep sort of trudging through the mud and being shot down and not using enough artillery and stuff. Is that fair, do you think? No, no, it isn't fair,
而且他们没有从错误中吸取教训。例如在帕斯尚尔战役中。这公平吗，还是你觉得这种批评……换句话说，你知道的，他们一直在泥泞中跋涉，被击倒，没有使用足够的火炮之类的东西。你觉得这公平吗？不，不，这不公平，
although it has an element of truth in it. Now, we used to talk about the learning curve that the British Army had, which we largely moved away from that because it implies a smooth upward transition. Actually, it isn't. I've baffled some of my students over the years by saying it's more like the learning Loch Ness Monster. It goes up and down and up again. There is not consistent learning of lessons.
尽管它包含了一点真相。现在，过去我们常谈论英国军队经历的学习曲线（learning curve），而我们基本上已经不再这么提了，因为这暗示了一种平稳向上的过渡。实际上并非如此。这些年来我曾把一些学生弄糊涂，我对他们说，这更像是学习尼斯湖水怪（learning Loch Ness Monster）。它时起时落，然后再上升。并没有持续不断的经验教训学习。
You do see mistakes made, same mistakes made over different periods. But it's more like a stepped progression. It's gradually going upwards. And during the Somme itself, I mean, the Somme is a battle which lasts from July to November 1916. And you do see some really significant advances,
你确实会看到犯错误，在不同的时期犯同样的错误。但这更像是一种阶梯式的进展。它在逐渐上升。索姆河战役本身——索姆河是一场从1916年7月持续到11月的战役——你确实看到了一些非常显著的进展，
both on the ground and actually in terms of technique you also see them say by same mistake over and over again in 1917 you see a major major advance in both sense the battle of arras in april and passchendaele which is a really interesting example because yes you do see some failures at the very beginning of the campaign. And that photo, Tom, is from, I think, early August 1917, where there's unseedably heavy rain. Actually, having looked out the window here, it's pouring. But only a month or so later, you have three dramatic victories as part of the third battle of which is the correct term for for passchendaele which brings the germans very very close to to to defeat in fact in the end i think it's only the breaking of the weather on the 4th of october 1917 which makes it very difficult for
无论是在地面上还是在战术上。你也看到了……比如说在1917年，你在两个意义上都看到了重大进展：4月份的阿拉斯战役，以及帕斯尚尔战役。这是一个非常有趣的例子，因为是的，你在战役刚开始时确实看到了一些失败。汤姆，那张照片大约摄于1917年8月初，当时有难以置信的暴雨。实际上，看看这里的窗外，雨正下得很大。但仅在一个月左右之后，作为第三次伊珀尔战役（这是帕斯尚尔的正确名称）的一部分，你赢得了三场戏剧性的胜利，这使得德国人非常、非常接近战败。事实上，最后我认为只有1917年10月4日天气的好转，才使得英国人很难继续推进。还有其他因素，可以说是拯救了德国人。尼克·劳埃德（Nick Lloyd）三四年前出版的关于帕斯尚尔的书，在这方面写得非常好。推特上提出的问题之一是，为什么德国人在1918年3月能够突破，而英法两国花了三年时间试图做到却失败了？嗯，英国人在1917年11月20日（康布雷战役的第一天）其实就已经突破了，而且它的影响与1918年德国人的突破
the british to continue their advances other factors as well which which would say it saves the germans uh nick lloyd's book on Passchendaele, published three or four years ago, is actually very good on this. And one of the questions which actually was posed on Twitter was why was it that the Germans broke through in March 1918 and the British and French had spent three years trying to do without failing? Well, the British had broken through on the 20th of November 1917, the first day of Combré, and it had much the same
大同小异。他们通过创新战术突破了敌人的战壕，在英国人的情况下还运用了技术，使用了坦克，但他们无法维持推进。因此，双方都在从自己的错误中学习，从战壕里的盟友那里学习，甚至从彼此的进攻和失误中学习。所以实际上，这是一个持续的进步。它并不是完美的。在战争结束时，由于各种原因，你仍然会发现有些部队比其他部队表现得更好。但确实有稳步的改善。当然，1918年11月的英国军队与1916年7月1日的英国军队相比，简直有着天壤之别，我认为这是一个公平的对比。
impact as the German breakthrough in 1918. They broke through the enemy trenches through the use of innovative tactics, in the British case technology as well, use of tanks, but they could not sustain the advance. So both sides were learning from their own mistakes, from their allies along the trenches, and indeed from each other's advances and mistakes. So actually, it is a continuous progress. It's not a perfect one. And at the end of the war, you still find some units are rather better than others, for all sorts of reasons. But there is a steady improvement. Certainly, the British Army of November 1918 is light years away from that of the 1st July 1916, which I think is a fair
好吧。德国人对此是有清醒认识的，对吧？从某种意义上说，从1914年底开始，德国人就注定要输掉战争，他们最终在1918年初孤注一掷，因为那个时刻即将来临，这是背水一战、放手一搏，否则不可避免的失败将会随之而来。正如我之前已经提到的那样，我其实认为德国人本应该争取达成一项外交解决，如果那样他们本可以带着（你知道的）一种妥协的结果走出来——他们归还西线占领的东西，他们将会以强大得多、强大得多的姿态出现。事实上，这也是英国外交官真正的恐惧，他们担心德国人会这样做，担心德国人会以一种
point of comparison. Okay. The Germans are conscious, aren't they, there? In a sense, the Germans are always going to lose from the end of 1914 onwards, and they're finally rolling the dice at the beginning of 1918 because that moment is looming and it's go for broke and gamble or inevitable defeat will will follow well as i think i've already mentioned i actually think the germans should have gone for a diplomatic settlement which they would have come out of you know with a compromise i they give back the stuff in the west they would emerge much much stronger and in fact it's a real fear with the british british foreign officers that's what they're going to do, that the Germans will come out of this stage of the war
妥协的和平走出战争的这个阶段，这会让他们变得更加强大，5年、10年或15年后，战争将会重燃，而德国人将占据更有利的优势。他们实际上是在回溯到1914年之前在英国被称为伟大战争的那场冲突，也就是拿破仑战争，当时你有一系列战役，然后是和平条约，或者至少没有发生太多事情，接着又是一轮战斗。他们认为这次也会是那样。德国人基本上做出了错误的决定，主要是因为我认为，
with a compromise speech which leaves them stronger, and there'll be a renewal of war 5, 10, 15 years down the line with the Germans in a much stronger advantage. They're actually looking back to what, until 1914, was called the Great War in Britain, that is, Napoleonic Wars, where you had a series of campaigns and then pieces, or at least there's not much going on, and then there there's another belt of fight they think it's going to be going to be like that the germans basically make the wrong decisions largely because i think that the
当时实际管理德国政府的两个关键人物是兴登堡和鲁登endorff（鲁登道夫），他们是高级指挥官，在很大程度上把平民政府推到了一边，而且在这个阶段德皇也只不过是一个傀儡。他们的战略视野非常、非常有限。他们只能看到在战场上取胜的途径，而不是通过谈判。所以他们全力以赴去赢得一切。我实际上应该在这个时候提一下美国人，因为肯定会有人问这样一个问题，你知道的，美国人赢得战争了吗？不，他们没有。现在，他们真的很重要，因为到1918年春季，他们正以非常庞大的数量抵达。德国人意识到，如果他们要赢得军事胜利，必须趁早，
people that the two key players who are running effectively running the german government at this time are hindenburg and ludendorff the senior commanders who have largely pushed the civilian government to one side and certainly the kaiser is not much more than a cipher at this stage. And they have very, very limited strategic vision. And they can only see the way to win is on the battlefield rather than by negotiating. And so they go in to win everything. I should actually mention the Americans at this point, because someone's bound to go ask a question, you know, did the Americans win the war? No, they didn't. Now, they are really important because they are arriving in very large numbers by the spring of 1918. And the Germans realise if they're going to win a military victory, it has to be soon
在美军以如此庞大的数量抵达、使他们根本不可能取胜之前。那么加里，对于那些不知道1918年发生的事情细节的人，你能否简要介绍一下局势的几次摇摆和来回？当然，好吧，德国人于1918年3月21日发起了他们的大规模进攻——“凯撒之战”（Kaiserschlag）。
before the Americans arrive in so large numbers they cannot possibly win. So Gary, could you just give, for people who don't know the details of what happens in 1918, just give a brief account of the swings and two and three of what happens. Sure, well, the Germans launched their major, the Kaiserschlag, the Kaiser's Battle, on the 21st of March, 1918.
他们进攻了英国第5集团军，这是实力最弱的英国集团军，由于兵力有限，被海格故意保持在较弱的状态。实际上那是位于最南端的部队。英国第5集团军，这是实力最弱的英国集团军，由于兵力有限，被海格故意保持在较弱的状态。实际上，那是位于最南端的部队。这是他最能够承受让出土地的部队，因为距离海岸还有相当长的一段距离。德国人突破了，但他们成功做到的全部事情只是把英法联军向后推，而并没有真正显著地突破他们的
They attacked British Fifth Army, which is the weakest British army, kept deliberately weak by Hague because there's only a limited number of troops. And actually that's the one furthest to the south. British Fifth Army, which is the weakest British army, kept deliberately weak by Haig because there's only a limited number of troops. And actually, that's the one furthest to the south. It's the one in which he could most afford to give ground because it's quite a distance to the coast. The Germans break through, but all they succeed in doing is pushing the British and the French back without actually significantly breaking through their
防线。原因在于，西线所有部队都受到一个不利条件的限制，那就是缺乏对战果的扩大利用。在拿破仑时代，他拥有骑兵，你知道的，你在敌人的防线上炸开一个缺口，把骑兵派进去，他们可以攻击步兵，他们可以冲进敌阵进行砍杀。25年后，你有了移动速度更快并能做同样事情的坦克。但在第一次世界大战中，骑兵嘛，它在那里，在一定程度上也很有用，但实际上你不能像拿破仑时期那样使用它，也不能像二战中的坦克那样使用它。因此，随着步兵的推进，
lines. And the reason for this is that something which handicaps all troops on the Western Front is the lack of a use of exploitation. In Napoleon's day, he had horse cavalry, you know, you bang a hole in the enemy lines, send the cavalry through, they can the infantry they can get among them they can chop them down 25 years later you have tanks which can move faster and do the same thing in the first world war cavalry well it's there and it's useful up to a point but really you cannot use it in the same way as in the polio period or tanks in the second world war therefore it as infantry is advancing uh the enemy infantry is falling back at roughly the same rate. And the Germans simply are unable to get among the retreating British, Canadians, Australian, French and all the rest of them and disperse them.
敌方步兵也以大致相同的速度后撤。德国人根本无法深入溃退的英国人、加拿大人、澳大利亚人、法国人及其他人当中去击溃他们。
So therefore, the Germans wear themselves out by launching fruitless attacks, having left their artillery behind because they've outrun their artillery. And they just waste their forces in attack after attack after attack. They become exhausted. The boot is on the other foot from late July, early August onwards when the Allies go on to the offensive. First of all, at the Second Battle of the Marne and then at the Battle of Amiens, the 8th of August 1918, the Black Day of the German Army, as it's described by senior Germans, when the British actually advance for eight miles in a single day. I should say British, it's the British, Australians, Canadians and French. And whereas the Germans in the spring have bashed a hole in enemy positions and just gone hell for
因此，由于炮兵落在后面（因为他们跑得比炮兵还快），德国人通过发起毫无结果的进攻耗尽了自己的体力。他们在一次又一次的进攻中浪费了他们的军队。他们精疲力竭。从7月下旬、8月上旬开始，当盟军转入反攻时，形势发生了逆转。首先是在马恩河第二次战役中，然后是在1918年8月8日的亚眠战役中——这一天被德国高级将领描述为“德国陆军的黑日”，当时英国军队在单日内推进了八英里。我应该说英国军队，其实是英国、澳大利亚、加拿大和法国军队。在春季时，德国人在敌方阵地上砸开一个缺口，然后拼命推进直到精疲力竭；而盟军则推进大约八到十英里，然后停下来，把进攻点转移到其他地方，推进，停下来，再重复同样的动作，在整个西线上进行相当浅纵深的推进，直到德国人再也无法维持防线，防线崩溃。他们能够做到这一点的方法之一，是英国的后勤水平甚至比帕斯尚尔时期有了显著的改善。现在你实际上拥有了轻便铁路和足够的汽车运输来运送人员、物资，至关重要的是将火炮从一个地方运到另一个地方，并在敌人的防线上砸开一个缺口。这就是盟军获胜的方式。实际上，他们进行了一系列相当浅纵深的推进。最终他们推进了50、60、70英里。
leather until they run out of steam, the Allies advance for about eight or ten miles, stop, move the point of attack to somewhere else, advance, stop, do the same again, pushing quite shallowly all along the Western Front until the Germans simply cannot sustain the Front any longer and it collapses. And one of the ways they're able to do this is because the British logistics has improved dramatically even since Passchendaele. You now actually have light railways and enough motor transport to move men and supplies and critically artillery from place to place and smash a hole in the enemy lines. And that's how the Allies win. Actually, they advance a series of quite shallow advances. They advance 50, 60, 70 miles in the end.
这不是戏剧性的推进。这不是海格想要的推进，但尽管如此，它非常高效。最终，德国人在1918年11月11日扔毛巾认输，因为他们再也无法支撑下去了。他们知道如果再打下去，德军将会彻底崩溃。所以我想快速插话一句。
It's not a dramatic advance. It's not the advance that Haig wants, but nonetheless, it's highly effective. And in the end, the Germans throw in the towel on the 11th of November, 1918, because they cannot stand any longer. They know if they go on any longer, the German army will collapse. So just to quickly jump in.
因此，我们的几位听众安德鲁·凯尔曼（Andrew Kelman）和斯蒂芬·克拉克（Stephen Clarke）（两人都是节目的老朋友）提出了一个问题，即在1918年的春季攻势中，德国人距离胜利有多近。你的回答会是，他们其实根本没有接近胜利，因为他们从来没有真正突破。他们只是把联军往后推。纯粹从军事角度来看，没有，他们没有接近。但真正的问题是，盟军最高指挥部当时认为发生了什么？因为，当然，完全有可能你在战场上没有取得多大成功，
So the question that a couple of our listeners, Andrew Kelman and Stephen Clarke, both friends of the show, have asked, which is how close the Germans come to winning in the spring offensive of 1918. Your answer would be they don't really come close at all because they're never breaking through. They're just pushing back. In purely military terms, no, they don't. But the real question is, what does the Allied high command think is going on? Because, of course, it's entirely possible you don't achieve much success on the battlefield,
但你却说服了敌人他们已经被击败了，于是他们投降了。在3月下旬（比如24、25、26日左右）有一段短暂的时期，局势确实看起来有些动摇。海格，这可以说是他唯一的一次——好吧，也是壕沟战开始后唯一的一次——患上了“胆怯症”（collywobbles）。实际上他很快就重振旗鼓了，但他真的很担心法国军队会往一个方向走，英国军队会往另一个方向走，而德国人会从中间穿过去。这里发生的事情是，一位法国将军——费迪南·福煦（Ferdinand Foch）被任命为最高盟军司令，不是作为法国军队的司令（这仍然由贝当担任），而是被任命为最高盟军司令来协调所有军队的行动。海格说的大意是，你知道的，“在福煦被任命后的第一天晚上，我终于睡了个好觉”，因为他认识并信任福煦，知道他有能力实际做出
but you persuade the enemy that they're beaten and they give in. And there's a brief period in late March, say around 24th, 25th, 26th, when it does seem a bit wobbly. Haig, really for the only time, well, the only time after trench warfare begins, gets an attack of the collie wobbles actually he rapidly regains his nerve but he really fears that the french army is going to go one way the british army is going the other and the germans will go through the center what happens here is that a french general um ferdinand foch is put in, not as commander of the French army, that remains with Pétain, but Foch is put in as supreme allied commander to coordinate the operations of all the armies. And Haig says it's to the effect that, you know, I slept well for the first night after Foch was appointed because he knew and trusted Foch and knew he was capable of actually taking decisions
符合整个联盟利益的决定，而不仅仅是为了法国军队的利益。因此福煦基本上就在那里分派军队，你知道的，对……说，“我们会派几个法国师去这里支援英国人，派英国人去那里”等等。具有讽刺意味的是，海格本人其实就是任命这样一位人物的主要原因之一（在1918年3月之前），因为海格热衷于保持自己的独立自主权。但当事到临头时，他意识到你需要这样一个人到位。当然，这必须是一个法国人，因为法国军队是最大的，而且法国人是战争中的高级伙伴。所以，不，德国人在战场上并没有接近胜利。他们距离说服盟军指挥官他们实际上已经战败，可能比人们想象的要近一些。但实际上，
in the interest of the coalition, not just of the French army. And so Foch basically was there sort of dolling out forces, you know, saying to, you know, we'll send a few French divisions here to relieve the Brits and Brits here and so on and so forth. What's ironic, actually, is that Haig himself was one of the principal reasons that someone like that had been appointed before March 1918, because Haig was keen to hang on to his autonomy. But when push came to shove, he realised you needed someone like him in place. Of course, it had to be a Frenchman, because the French army was the largest, and the French were the senior partners in the war. So no, the Germans did not come close to winning on the battlefield. They came perhaps closer than one might think to persuading the Allied commanders that actually they were beaten. But actually,
为了联合国的利益，不仅仅是为了法国军队。因此，福煦基本上是在那里分发军队，你知道的，对……说，我们会派几个法国师去支援英国人，这里派英国人等等。实际上具有讽刺意味的是，黑格本人是1918年3月之前任命这样一个人主要原因之一，因为黑格热衷于保持自己的独立性。但到了紧要关头，他意识到你需要这样一个人就位。当然，这必须是一个法国人，因为法国军队是最大的，法国人是战争中的高级合伙人。所以不，德国人并没有接近在战场上取胜。他们可能比人们想象的更接近于说服盟军指挥官他们实际上已经被击败了。但实际上，
it was only a brief window of opportunity and in the end, nothing came of it. Okay, so Gary, we're drawing to a close. But one last question, which I think is a really interesting one from David Paxton, again, great friend of the show. And he asks, I guess looking ahead to the sequel, World War II,
那只是一次短暂的机遇之窗，到头来，什么也没有发生。好的，加里，我们即将结束。但有一个最后一个问题，我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，来自大卫·帕克斯顿，也是节目的好朋友。他问，展望续集，也就是第二次世界大战，
how many more weeks would the war have to have lasted for the germans to have experienced undeniable unspinnable collapse and defeat and kill off all risk of the stab in the back um as a credible and useful um tool of propaganda that's a really great question i suspect not many actually two or three interestingly haig came quite defensive about this after the war and i think the only time I ever saw him comment on this, he argues basically that, well, you know, the Germans were obviously beaten, so why carry on and cause more casualties? Also, pertinently, the Allies actually
德国人还需要再坚持多少个星期，才会经历无可否认、无法粉饰的崩溃与失败，从而彻底消灭“背后刺刀”说作为一种可信且有用的宣传工具的任何风险？这真是个好问题。我猜实际上没几个星期，也就两三周吧。有趣的是，黑格在战后对此进行了一些辩解，我想这也是我唯一一次看到他对这一点发表评论。他基本上认为，嗯，你知道的，德国人显然已经被击败了，那为什么还要继续下去造成更多伤亡呢？此外，切中要害的是，盟军实际上
are outrunning their supply lines. So they would have found it very difficult to sustain a major advance for very much further. But there's another way around this problem, because actually the Germans are at such a state on the 11th of November, that actually the Allies could have asked for much harsher armistice terms than they give. So basically had all the German armies had to pass into prisoner of war camps, and you had Allied victory parades in Berlin and Munich,
正在超越他们的补给线。因此，他们会发现很难再进一步维持大规模的推进。但这个问题还有另一种解决方法，因为事实上，在11月11日时，德国人的状况已经如此糟糕，以至于盟军本可以提出比实际情况更为苛刻的停战条件。所以基本上，如果让所有德国军队都进入战俘营，并且让盟军在柏林和慕尼黑举行胜利游行，
I think that would have rubbed it home. As it was, I think, a combination of Allied war weariness and actually very good logistic reasons for not wanting to push on. And the fact the German army may have lost the war, but they're extremely good at winning the narrative about how it wasn't really them that lost the war. It was actually the politicians, the Jews and the Bolsheviks at home, which of course is complete nonsense. The German army did really well at shaping the narrative, even though they were hopeless at fighting the war. All I'd say as a concluding point about this, come the sequel, as you call it,
我想那会给他们留下极其深刻的印象。当时的实际情况是，盟军的战争疲劳感与不愿继续推进的非常合理的后勤原因结合在了一起。尽管德国军队可能输掉了战争，但他们在如何塑造“并非他们真正输掉战争，而是国内的政客、犹太人和布尔什维克害的”这一叙事方面，表现得极其出色——当然这完全是无稽之谈。德国军队在塑造叙事方面做得非常出色，尽管他们在打仗方面一塌糊涂。关于这一点，我最后要说的是，到了你所说的续集，
the Second World War, the Allies make really, really sure they're not allowed to do that again. There's a very, very different, much harsher piece imposed on Germany in 1945, of course. Okay, well, that's brilliant, Gary. Thanks so much. I mean, so much to talk about, you know, lifetime of scholarship compressed into an hour. So thank you.
即第二次世界大战时，盟军绝对确保他们不会再被允许那样做。当然，1945年强加给德国的是一份截然不同、严厉得多的和平条约。好的，太棒了，加里。非常感谢。我的意思是，有太多东西要谈了，毕生的学术研究浓缩在一个小时里。所以谢谢你。
Thank you so much. And I hope that all your listeners have enjoyed it. It's, you know, I mean, it's a tough subject, but such a fascinating one. And we will be back soon with more historically themed podcastery we will indeed, thank you Gary
非常感谢。我希望所有的听众都喜欢它。你知道的，这是一个沉重的话题，但又如此迷人。我们很快就会带着更多历史主题的播客回归。确实如此，谢谢你，加里。
goodbye everybody, see you next time bye bye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History for bonus episodes early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
大家再见，下次见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。